señor vela un placer tenerlo aquí en
france 24 la mujer tiene más de 3500
observadores desplegados por todo el
país en este momento cuéntenos que
observaron en ese primer reporte que ya
sacó el organismo
buenas tardes si tenemos estos
observadores en distintos municipios del
país 264 en particular y nos han
reportado 119 reportes principalmente
temas lo que tiene que ver con testigos
electorales problemas con las
acreditaciones el tema las
irregularidades a la libertad del voto
con 28 reportes con esto incluidas las
acá se incluyen las compras de los votos
irregulares en la publicidad personas
que ingresan con camps a que con logos
de campañas en las puestas de votación y
finalmente
problemas con los puestos en los
continuos consulados que están en las en
el lado colombiano y en la pasada
elección en colombia se cubrió con un
manto de dudas el escrutinio de las
votaciones al congreso tardó más de una
semana algo atípico en el país de hecho
varios congresistas perdieron su escaño
a pesar de que en el preconteo salían
como ganadores y múltiples políticos
pidieron la renuncia del registrador
nacional alexander vega quien sigue en
su cargo explíquenos por favor qué fue
lo que ocurrió en esos comicios y cómo
impactan en las presidenciales
el problema que hago para la selección
de congresos tuvo que ver con el
preconteo otros que es un proceso
meramente informativa es decir esto no
son los votos reales que cuentan
finalmente para los curules del congreso
sino es para informar el día a las
elecciones cuál ha sido más o menos el
panorama de la de la votación estuvo un
problema con la transmisión de datos
donde muchos votos para algunas campañas
políticas no se transmitieron y por lo
tanto no se reportaron y por lo tanto u
ese cambio tan radical entre el
escrutinio el preconteo esto claramente
generó problemas en la confianza de la
registraduría y por lo tanto por la
registraduría estuvo en estos últimos
meses haciendo un poco de medidas y
mesas técnicas para mejorar todo lo que
tiene que ver con el proceso electoral y
está en forma evitar que se repitan los
mismos problemas para estas elecciones y
si bien se está intentando que se eviten
esos problemas y esas diferencias entre
el escrutinio y el preconteo que tanta
legitimidad cree usted que tiene la
registraduría nacional de colombia para
las votaciones de hoy
lamentablemente se perdió mucho la
confianza en la registraduría y el
proceso electoral esto pues es un
agravante bastante preocupante de cara a
lo que pueden ser los resultados tanto
de primera y segunda vuelta acá
claramente la rectoría de proveer las
garantías y dar todos los pasos
necesarios para que las campañas
políticas reconozcan y en legítima este
proceso por lo tanto cada ceder si se
quiere un gran esfuerzo no sólo el día
de hoy sino también las próximas semanas
y llegar a la segunda vuelta de manera
que mejore toda esta confianza en el
proceso electoral